Nearly $1 million in sanctions.
That's what a federal judge
is ordering former
President Trump
and one of his lawyers
to pay it over a lawsuit
they filed against Hillary Clinton,
former top Justice Party
officials and several others
alleging that the nearly three dozen
defendants
conspired against Trump
in the 2016 campaign.
Judge Donald
Middlebrook issuing
a scathing rebuke of the case,
writing, quote,
This case should never have been brought.
Its inadequacy
as a legal claim
was evident from the start.
No reasonable lawyer would have filed it,
ripping some of Trump's
claims, writing, quote, It was not that
the complaint and amended
complaint were inadequate in any respect.
They were inadequate in nearly
every respect.
And pointing out Trump's habit
of using the courts for his own purposes.
Writing Mr.
Trump is a prolific
and sophisticated litigant
who was repeatedly using the courts
to seek revenge on political adversaries.
He is the mastermind
of strategic abuse
of the judicial process,
and he cannot be seen as a litigant
blindly following the advice of a lawyer.
He knew full
well the impact of his actions.
And as of tonight, Trump and his team
have dropped another lawsuit.
They filed that one against New York
Attorney General Letitia James.
For more on all of this,
I want to bring in CNN legal analyst
Elliott Williams
and Donald Trump
biographer Michael D'Antonio.
Glad to see you both here.
First of all, Eliot,
this judge was not mincing
any words in his review of this lawsuit.
What was your reaction?
Well, first off,
you know, I clerked
for Judge Middlebrooks.
In a past life, maybe 20 years ago.
And so, you know,
I've seen his opinions over the years.
This was a very remarkable opinion.
And I think
there's a lot of focus
on sort of the bombast and the,
you know, Trump versus the law.
This is actually a very meticulous
legal opinion
laying out the standard
for when you sanction an attorney,
what it takes,
how they calculate the fees
and what the law says and what.
And also, looking back at past conduct,
you know,
they point out the fact
that the former president sued
the Pulitzer board
over the fact that the Pulitzers
were given
to The New York Times,
The Washington Post,
in making a case
that this was just a frivolous lawsuit.
And now we should also note this.
900 plus thousand dollars.
It wasn't just a number
pulled out of thin air.
It's for attorney's fees. And costs.
And the judge walks through
and again, in great detail
how you tabulate that $1 million.
So it's not
I think folks have in their head
that this judge just got mad
at Donald Trump
and then threw $1,000,000 fine at him.
It's just it's far more complicated
and legally supported than that.
Michael,
it almost seems he's talking about this
and you hear about it in the press
the idea
and you've written about the idea of
sort of the Trump
playbook, so to speak,
the idea of some litigants
essentially not being able
to go against the best lawyers
that money can possibly buy.
What is your reaction to this?
Well, I do
think that the judge has noted
one of the constant themes
when you examine
Donald Trump's tactics and methods,
he sues people for a variety of reasons
and rarely
does that have anything
to do with justice.
He wants to punish people
by draining their bank accounts.
He wants to attract publicity
and he wants to deflect
the public's attention
from his own misdeeds.
So the very first lawsuit he ever filed
was in 1973 when he had his pit bull.
Roy Cohn alleged that the Justice
Department had acted as a Gestapo force
in trying to get him
to stop
discriminating against
minority applicants for apartments.
I think the judge noted many cases
where Trump has done similar things.
I think he could write his own
biography of Donald Trump,
given what I've seen in the ruling.
So he got it all right.
He was one of the rare
places where Trump met accountability.
And this is something
people ask about all the time.
When will this man be held accountable?
Well, here
is one case where he has been
held accountable.
Elliot
is this telling about his approach
that we've talked about more broadly
and how he views lawyers
or even the justice system
when he was the head
of the executive branch?
Yeah, you know, it's interesting
you know,
and we talk about this idea of
when will this person
be held accountable.
You ought to sort of treat
every instance as unique.
You know,
the fact that
one person
is suing Donald Trump
for one jurisdiction
is seeking to prosecute them.
They all get sort of mixed together.
And, you know,
I think an opinion like this
is very important
and sort of,
you know, in isolation in this case,
what we've seen is how
you can sort of lay out a case,
you know,
based on the facts and law in one matter
as opposed to pulling everything else.
And so, you know, it was just
I think it was very powerfully written
and well-reasoned and organized.
And I think that just should be noted.
And it's true of the idea of conflation
being a dangerous vehicle, especially.
We'll talk about Donald Trump.
Everything seems to come together
and they go, it is part of this.
And this judge seemed to make very clear
is about this case in this moment.
Thank you so much, everyone.